la ministre de la transition énergétique
Agnès panière une hachée était
aujourd'hui en visite en Indre-et-Loire
et plus précisément à la centrale
nucléaire de Chinon un déplacement pour
faire le point sur le programme de
redémarrage des deux réacteurs encore à
l'arrêt objectif retrouvé au plus vite
la production habituelle plus
d'explications avec les Turquie
visite guidée dans la salle des machines
ce vendredi la centrale nucléaire de
Chinon ouvre ses portes à la ministre de
la transition énergétique Agnès panier
rue naché à l'heure où 24 réacteurs
nucléaires sont encore à l'arrêt en
France la ministre se veut rassurante
nous suivons avec mes équipes EDF et RTE
c'est remise sur le réseau des réacteurs
et je redis à EDF que je compte sur
l'engagement que j'ai pu observer des
équipes pour faire en sorte que nous
entamions l'hiver dans les meilleures
conditions possibles ici à Chinon deux
réacteurs sur 4 sont arrêtés l'un depuis
9 mois pour maintenance suite au
phénomène de corrosion et l'autre depuis
15 jours pour une économie de
combustible mais plus pour très
longtemps d'ici la semaine prochaine les
deux réacteurs devraient être de nouveau
en production et le plus ancien d'entre
eux fêtent ces 40 ans en 2023 alors EDF
réfléchit déjà à l'avenir de pas
centrale si on part les principes
qu'elles vont continuer jusqu'à 60 ans
c'est les réacteurs qu'on va arrêter
entre 2043 et 2050 et à Chinon on a de
l'ordre de 100 hectares de fonciers qui
peuvent être utilisés pour d'éventuelles
nouveaux projets dont d'éventuels
nouveaux projets nucléaires en réflexion
à long terme la construction de PR des
réacteurs nouvelle génération 6 sont en
construction en France pour le moment de
son côté la centrale nucléaire de Chinon
produit à elle seule un peu plus de 5%
de l'électricité consommée par an dans
l'Hexagone